أريد أن أذهب الآن إلى الفريق المتقاعد بالجيش
بن هودجز
والجنرال. أريد أن أبدأ معكم ببعض
اللقطات غير العادية التي
نشرتها صحيفة وول ستريت جورنال لأول مرة،
وما ننظر إليه هنا هو
خندق يمين جنود روس يائسين
في هذا  الخندق محاصر هناك
طائرة بدون طيار أوكرانية مسلحة تحلق
فوقه وهذا على أه
الخطوط الأمامية المدمرة تماما في باكموت لذلك
ترى هذا الجندي على اليمين وترى
أه الانفجارات حوله
زملائه الجنود يموتون على
الأرض أنت  يمكنه رؤية
العديد من الموتى، لذا فهو يتوسل
من أجل حياته ويتواصل عن طريق
إيماءات اليد مع الطائرة بدون طيار، وهو ما
إذا كان شخص ما يقوم بتشغيل الطائرة بدون طيار من مسافة
بعيدة لذا فهو يتواصل، كما ترى هناك،
يرسل له المشغل ملاحظة تخبره
بتسليم الطائرة بدون طيار
في النهاية  يرشده إلى موقع أوكراني
حيث يتم أسره، إنها
لقطات مذهلة جدًا لمشاهدة الجنرال ما رأيك
فيها كما تراها
جيدًا وهذا يؤكد ما اعتقدناه
آرون بأن معظم هؤلاء
الجنود الروس لا يريدون أن يكونوا هناك  إنهم
لا يثقون في قيادتهم،
ولم يتم تدريبهم أو تجهيزهم بشكل صحيح،
وهم يعلمون أنهم في وضع سيء للغاية،
لذا يرى جندي كهذا
فرصة وبالطبع الأوكرانيون بشكل روتيني
مبتكرون وكيف يفعلون
أشياء جديدة باستخدام الطائرات بدون طيار  وهذا
يذكرني أيضًا بعاصفة الصحراء، ربما تتذكر أنه كان هناك
العديد من الجنود العراقيين الذين
استسلموا لطائرة هليكوبتر ولم
يرغبوا في التواجد هناك،
إنه لأمر مدهش رغم ذلك مشاهدتها
وأنت تعرف أنك
تتحدث دائمًا عن كيفية عمل الطائرات بدون طيار  منفصل
عن المشغل تمامًا في هذه الحالات،
حيث يوجد العديد من مشغلي الطائرات بدون طيار في مكان
قريب جدًا
ويمكن للطائرة بدون طيار العودة وإسقاط الملاحظة فقط
لتخيل الأمر برمته
الإنسانية وسط هذا آه كان لوح فريد الخاص بنا
يظهر اليوم للتو  كما تعلم
أنه اضطر إلى الاحتماء لأنهم كانوا
قلقين بشأن القصف الجوي الواضح
في منطقة وصفها بأنها
حركية للغاية وتشهد الكثير من القصف، وهذه
هي المناطق التي
أبلغ فيها الأوكرانيون عن بعض النجاح الجزئي في
الهجوم المضاد وقد سمعتم  هل
جيني بريغوسيان أه قال بشكل عام اليوم
إن الأوكرانيين يتحركون
بشكل منهجي وأن على روسيا أن تفعل المزيد،
ما هي وجهة نظرك للوضع على
الأرض الليلة، جنرال
حسنًا،
من المثير للاهتمام أو المثير للسخرية أن السيد
باغوسيان ربما يكون
مصدر المعلومات الأكثر موثوقية من الروس
الجانب أه، إنه من مصلحته
بالطبع أن تجتمع هيئة الأركان العامة الروسية
لتبدو
غير فعالة أه هذا جزء منه
جزء من نموذج أعماله لكنني عندما
استمعت إلى ما كان يقوله أعتقد
أنه كان  من المقنع أن هناك نوعًا
من الاحترام الذي
يبديه الأوكرانيون على الجانب الأوكراني، فقد
سلكوا الطريق الآن لتحرير شبه
جزيرة القرم وطرد
الروس من بلادهم، لكن ما
زالت الأيام مبكرة كما تعلم، أعني أن
هناك  سيكون هناك الكثير من الارتباك في
التقارير التي تعود إلى القادة
بشأن ما يحدث، هذه
هي طبيعة الحرب، أعني
أنه سيكون هناك بعض
عدم اليقين ولكن لا أعتقد أننا نرى ما
رأيناه  الهجوم الرئيسي ولكن
عندما تبدأ في رؤية اثنين أو ثلاثة لواء مدرع كبير يضم
مئات المركبات معًا، فهذا هو
الهجوم الرئيسي